happy friday everybody let's get cooking
with nanny bubby in her kitchen today
she's showing us how to prepare a
delicious kentucky derby pie hey nanny
bubby
hello hey there rocky hello hello
happy kentucky derby weekend thank you
thank you um
i i i feel underdressed i feel
underdressed
you look fabulous you can never thank
you listen
i i have to tell you you know in 2020 we
lost so many
traditions and it is so great that in
2021
we've been through march madness and now
we're on to the kentucky derby the first
saturday in may and i myself had the
great experience in 2005
to be invited to the kentucky derby with
my husband i think you might see a
picture right now
of the hat i wore in 2005 do you see
that
yes we do and you look fabulous again
this is your thing this is your thing
this is my thing that year
i actually won the kentucky derby and i
just want to give you a hint how i did
it
number one when the horses come out on
the tr yes i won
when the horses came out on the track to
do their little parade if a
horse goes big potty on the track that's
a good sign it means they've lightened
up a little you know how
that's right okay okay if you combine
big potty with a color i like and a name
i like that's a winner for me
so that year giacomo did all three of
those and so i better him
what i didn't know is he was the long
shot that day
and needless to say he was the biggest
long shot in the history of the derby to
ever win the race and
this is the uh he paid 50 to one so that
day it meant something to me
and i always loved that memory so i'm so
thrilled to be here today today thank
you for sharing that
thank you for sharing that after after
your horse wins you you feed them pie i
guess
yeah well no you feed the winner's pie
you feed the people pie
right right so here we go one one cup
sugar
to a half a cup of flour
this is for the filling um we are going
to put in one teaspoon
of vanilla
right here and we are going to put in
lightly beaten eggs that are room
temperature if they're not room
temperature you can bring them to room
temperature
by putting them in warm water this in
the shell
and that will bring them to room
temperature and then melted but cooled
butter do you want to know why this
butter needs to be cool
of course i do it sounds like any secret
no i want to know why i don't know why
because
because you don't want to turn these
eggs into scrambled eggs
use them to make your filling and then
we're going to put in guitar
chocolate chips right here and look at
how you get this at target or whole
foods or sprouts but look at how big and
beautiful these chips are oh yeah
okay like i caught like cool yeah oh my
god they're so delicious
i keep stealing one out every once in a
while i'm like oh you know if you missed
one or two of these
i'm chopping up walnuts just to show you
these are the easiest nut to chop
and just a rough chop on these just put
them right into the mix
and we're going to mix that up crunch
yes and just sweet and beautiful
and so let me tell you one of the tricks
this
pie crust in the interest of time is
already made but i want to give you a
pro tip
on the pie crust is that it usually
calls for tablespoons of ice water
but the tip is don't use ice water in
your
crust use bourbon or vodka because the
alcohol stifles the gluten development
and nothing makes a pie crust tougher
than gluten
and so if it develops it's a terrible
crust but if it doesn't develop
it is a fabulous crust so this pie crust
and pie crust is the most important part
i mean the filling is
important but the crust is the
foundation
yes indeed so we are put this right into
the pie
this is a silicone liner for the crust
and
that keeps the crust from burning when
you put it in we're going to walk
right over to the oven and we are going
to put this
in but due to the magic of television we
are going to pull out
this fabulous done pie i'll show you how
beautiful this is wow
and actually fairly easy this was pretty
simple
oh very easy and if you don't basically
it tastes like a baked chocolate chip
cookie in a pie
now this is too hot for me to take off
the silicone liner
but there you go let me get that in can
we can we just dig in because we got a
wrap in a second here can we just dig in
to see the filling
yes yes take a look at this i'm going to
eat it for you look at that it's like a
chocolate chip cookie in a pie
oh look at that my gosh and i'm going to
eat this with a fabulous mint julep okay
ready let me get a big piece
oh we're all in here very upset that
we're not with you right now nanny bubby
happy kentucky happy kentucky derby
and stay with me together on the count
of three go out and spread love love
like i love that thank you so much nanny
bubby
so good but outlook you're mouthful
check out nanny bubby's kitchen and
garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com we also
want to thank chapman automotive for
sponsoring this segment